[Musique]
les provinces de madagascar 6 2 par la
retenue de part leur danse et aussi de
par leur culture
et c'est cette diversité qui va faire
l'unité et bien sûr madagascar est fait
on sait vivre ensemble un tacle et rien
d'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un grand moment de bonheur on voit ce
que quand on célèbre l'amitié franco
malgache on ne peut être heureux parce
que nous même bien sûr beaucoup de
réunionnais nous sommes aussi nous avons
des origines malgaches et parfois bien
sûr chacun a des problèmes dans sa vie
tous les jours je souffre il ya des
moments il faut savoir aussi célébrer
notre amitié et ça c'est un grand moment
de joie
[Musique]
zhu
ici se vit la république en mieux
le père donc pas sûr ah parce que si
nous perdons cela nous allons perdre au
fond les fondements même de toute
république
les valeurs que nous défendons liberté
égalité fraternité mafraq hamilton
elle doit survivre devenons et restons
fraternelle c'est ce qui a toujours lié
le peuple malgache au peuple français et
réunionnais c'est cela
[Musique]
il y a des complémentarités à pâtir sur
l'ensemble de la zone afin qu'ensemble
nous puissions nourrir durablement nos
populations et renfoncer ainsi la
sécurité alimentaire et nutritionnelle
de tout façade vite indianocéanique en
malgache un proverbe qui dit ferme ta
factset sargasses parce que c'est à dire
que quand on se rassemble en tous tu
divorces mécontents se rassemblent pas
quand on se disperse
on n'est rien du tout on n'est que de la
poussière du sable donc il faut il faut
qu'on soit puni ou pour faire quelque
chose surtout si on est loin du pays
natal c'est qu'on soit solidaires dans
tous les domaines dans tous les sens du
terme
pour qu'on soit reconnu que la culture
magasin apprécié par le peuple est donné
à tous nos amis malgaches va le faire
joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]